je vous assure le dr françois et moi
nous sommes très inquiets nuit ne parle
presque plus il passe son temps dans le
jardin à un marché en ouvrant grand la
bouche
n'ont aucun son ne sort de sa bouche
est vraiment impossible
d'accord
dont nous le quittons pas des yeux enfin
docteur qu'est ce qu'il a dit est paraît
il ne peut pas venir pour l'instant il a
les malades allez voir il ya des
possibles il nous conseille de pia
l'observer
attention justement le voilà qui arrive
peut-être ne torture pas assez et sa
fille bayer ou alors il est devenu muet
du présent c'était pouvant table
on dirait qu'ils voient rien non plus si
vous arrêtez de dire des stupidités je
pourrais à continuer à travailler alors
c'est incroyable ça
tu le penses toi aussi tu y as you
really pas du tout dans son état normal
mais dis-moi julie tu crois qu'on peut
devenir fou comme ça on à ce jour
l'agencé victoria qu'il faut admettre
que casimir a toujours été complètement
stupide quoi tu dis toi même que tu as
toujours été complètement stupide moi
non mais c'est ce que vous racontez
depuis tout à l'heure qui est pardonnez
moi complètement stupide à la merci
quand même mais comme casimir si tu nous
expliquer ce qui t'arrive peut-être
qu'on ne poserait pas comme ça des
questions stupides complètement stupide
complètement si tu veux mais pourquoi
marche qui sans rien dire en ouvrant la
bouche je travaille mon vocabulaire
j'apprends une langue étrangère à ses
fantasmes mais j'aurais jamais pensé à
ça revient sur toi pour ce qui est de la
communication entre les peuples tu as
toujours été en retard et quelle langue
apprend tu as ça c'est un secret ah oui
et là tu parles de touba comme ça on
entend pas on comprend rien et après tu
nous fais la surprise tu vois casimir
j'ai tout compris
rien du tout tu n'as rien compris du
tout voilà alors que imi en est aux
vaches pie ix pic nous pourquoi qui
apprend une langue étrangère je reviens
mais à une condition c'est que lui s'en
aille on peut très bien être bien très
bien parfait puisque c'est comme ça moi
je m'en vais ça tombe bien j'aime et
ballon allait ranger au revoir je lis
calais on voit qu'ils me voir
et bien voilà tu sais l'autre jour en
allant crampes et métiers dans la
rivière eh bien j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
que je vais te dire par quelqu'un et
bien c'est
une demoiselle est jolie ah oui elle est
très belle elle a des des grands yeux
noirs une couleur un petit peu comme la
mienne mais avec des reflets rouge et
doré
malheureusement nous ne parlons pas la
même langue alors on n'a pas pu se
comprendre c'est pour ça que je
travaille mais quelle langue par le
talent l'anglais non l'allemand non le
rookie italien n'a maintenant je peux
pas te dire encore c'est c'est un secret
trouve et il nous l'a présenté
j'aimerais la connaît oui je pense bien
je serais ravi d'avoir une nouvelle amie
c'est vrai écoute je vais aller la voir
et puis si elle veut bien je la ramène
d'accord d'accord elle s'appelle
pénélope at il dit moi je suis beau oui
tu te répond qu'une glace
ça va aller dépêche-toi joueur de
l'avoir mais oui mais oui des très
belles comme sa
nouvelle à t'annoncer qu'elle casimir
est recherché la demoiselle étrangères
pour laquelle il apprend cette
mystérieuse landreau paraît qu'elle est
très jolie tragédie
coquet copine julie
voilà je vous présente pénélope
mais depuis quelque chose
si vous avez un chien eh bien j'espère
que vous êtes de bons maîtres comme moi
j'ai savais pas quoi au bout de la
ficelle un adorable petit chien comme à
envoyer mon oncle archibald
il s'appelle molosses et et nous allons
être très amis m'ont lancé mois regardez
comme il est mignon
mais
ça alors me lance maintenant souhait qu
revient aux pieds me lance aux pieds
sales heureuse qu'il ait passé mal en ce
moment où es tu reviens on revient vite
jolie lily tu n'as pas vu mon nom j'ai
pas vu mais le fait qu'ils aient
molosses bon c'est vrai j'ai pas eu le
temps de t'expliquer voulons c'est un
adorable petit chien commun comment
renvoyer mon oncle archibald
mais sur les paires du regard il ne
reste que le collier oh la la un chien
perdu sans collier ça sera difficile à
retrouver un bon je vais voir françois
françois provient qui n'a pas vu mon
nouvel ami tout nouvel ami qui s mais
c'était mal à son adorable petit chien
non au moulin voulait que j'ai mûri n'y
a pas de voleurs dans l'île aux enfants
qu'un petit que juillet moi nous allions
à sa recherche on met julie elle perd
toujours tout alors non mais si monsieur
merlan fumée était là que
commodités tu sèmes merluche français
mermet relance mais enfin le plus grand
détective du monde ah oui j'y suis
kazemi je veux parler de monsieur
merlotte folle naissent c'est ça oui je
suis sûr qu'il le retrouve casey mais ça
tombe bien parce que tout à l'heure j'ai
justement rencontré sur le port mais
j'ai envie de chercher françois il ne
faut pas perdre de temps dac engagement
d'accord d'accord j'y cours
je suis certain qu'il va me retrouver
aucun doute possible ok le possible
c'est bien les lauzes un
bonjour mademoiselle julie à bonjour
monsieur roch fan's bonjour monsieur
casimir vous êtes enfin la motion merlus
fumée mais la famille oui mais l'homme
enfin comme vous dites voilà je sais
mais
ça c'est si vous le retrouvez vous aurez
une énorme récompense n'est pas la peine
soit il pour la gloire de chez casimir
et la reine d'angleterre qu'elle est la
récompense vient cet homme un énorme
super glue bulgare géant j'ai dit
monsieur avoue trouver vraiment cela
délicieux de nous et julie je suis un
détective anglais
que pensez-vous de mon affaire et vient
monsieur casimir votre affaire très
compliquée rien ici pas facile pour wii
et bien mais c'est que gmail si votre
chien n'est pas ici c'est une et
ailleurs vous avez fait vous avez dû
faire des études énorme pour prouver sa
console il dit nous comment est touché à
casimir mais j'ai laissé jeu qui mène au
caire est en feu
excusez moi mais
je croyais vous être utile c'est là
j'adore les témoignages spontanés
juillet vous appelez les enfants si vous
n'êtes emma côté une tâche de thé c'est
vrai vous êtes anglais les enfants
venaient mais si vous êtes vous
venez rites les arrêts mais vous pouvez
vous asseoir au juge de la jeunesse
associez vous tout cela
voilà vous savez reçu follement c est
extraordinaire c'est le plus grand
détective du monde alors là le casino
chien a disparu est-ce que les deux vous
non je te nuit je lui
personne ne l'a vu voilà votre
folie voudriez vous grenoble se cache
différentes gravure et les moqueries aux
offres s'il vous plaît avec joie
les enfants quelle est leur s ii se
chier
c'est bien ça y est votre chien était-il
un lévrier mais s'était dit mieux non
non non non non le mien était plus et à
enfin - moi je vois que je vois je
voudrais un autre s'il vous plaît ne
nous a dit qu'elle est le reste de ses
chiens se sont
chauds et est chercheur au nom non pas
du tout non c'était pas
pourquoi
elle sait tous étaient en baisse et à
tes yeux alors que 10000 à
15000 n'ont rien à voir ce qui est
excellent et nous
il est très rigolo celui ci je trouve
moi
[Applaudissements]
tu connais tous les ingénieurs monsieur
et tout ça nous menons s'il était bien
plus bien aura été différent quoi
magnifique est celle où on l'appelle
comme encore le ciel ou wii abondé
allemand
benoît julie le monsieur casimir au nom
alors vraiment pas non plus compliqué
est inquiète d'incroyables faut sortir
les gelées et bien il n'y en a plus
[Musique]
ce tonnage dont le mystère s'épaissit
concentrez vous monsieur casimir
concentrez-vous il faut que je sorte de
cette impasse
votre chien le savez est il un signe
particulier ah non je ne vois pas quand
et sur casimir
merci mon chien mois avec quelque chose
que tous ces chiens là non pas que
peut-être le but qu'est ce que c'est eh
bien il avait quatre petites roulettes
sur les pattes
quatre petites roulettes
casimir tout chien s'était jouée ce
n'est pas à vous et chez darty c'est un
ancien jouets quoi ou à jouer chien
soutien je sais ce que monkey moulante
je sais que chaque cas si j'ai les vues
quittera dès ce matin dans le jardin je
les ramasse et je les mets dans la malle
magique merci je suis
ça y est votre chien petit je sais où il
est il est d'un retrait magique mail
olalala pourvu que la main elle ne l'est
pas transformer en hérisson crapuleux
que j'allais m'en faire des farces et je
vais regarder si tu veux je te plaît il
est bien ici
casimir ton chat s'est transformé en
quoi on est vrai petit chien ok comme il
est mignon
il est formidable
oh mais c'est kevin et vous êtes le
peuple
non ce n'est pas à vous que je parlais
monsieur wolf s forme s tsé-tsé de mon
petit mot lance
ok
[Musique]